foreign
okay we'll be starting in about two
minutes
just coming up on the top of the hour in
India and bottom of the hour North
America
we'll be starting shortly
recording in progress
North America
we'll be starting shortly
recording in progress
we're just about a minute away
so we have our LinkedIn live audience we
should be uh having our YouTube live
audience joining shortly
and
we'll get it started
just about 30 seconds
right
so let's begin
I want to welcome everyone to our career
information session about the project
management
postgraduate program from UMass Amherst
my name is Stuart Creek I'm with simply
learn we are the delivery partner
UMass and uh I'll be talking about the
program
also uh you'll hear from
Brian Campbell who is
one of our senior instructors
um
well
introduce him in a moment
right now I want to talk about the
agenda
we're going to talk about project
management careers I'll be asking you a
few poll questions along the way
then we'll talk about what this program
offers you
and how it gets you uh job ready for
project management careers
we will talk about enrollment steps if
it's something you're interested in and
then we'll take your questions so along
the way if questions have come up uh
occur to you please put them in the Q a
if you're watching on our streaming
service put them into the
comment or chat box
should be able to get
those
transferred over to me so I can answer
those in the Q a section toward the end
of the presentation so
with that I am going to
um
let you hear from Brian now
so uh hello everyone it's great to spend
a little time with you
um so yes I am a uh a a project program
manager
um these acronyms you see in front of
you stand for things like the project
management professional the program
management professional and the project
management institute's agile certified
professional all these are
certifications offered by the project
management Institute which is sort of
the leading project
um
body authorization certification body so
I do a lot of work with PMI as well as a
lot of work in traditional and more
agile related practices
and I've been doing this for a long time
I think both Stuart and I current relate
to the fact that you know we start
getting a lot more gray here uh
appearing and that's just a sign of all
the the time we've spent working in
different organizations so most of my
background has been exclusively project
and program management experience
oftentimes helping organizations with
things in large-scale Transformations we
want to shift from traditional project
management to maybe to Agile so I do a
lot of work in that space I contribute a
lot to some of the literature out in the
industry like the project management
body of knowledge or pin block and I do
a lot of work with organizations like
simply learn creating course content to
help people that want to learn more
about project management and get their
certifications
um
about careers in project management
project management is a universal skill
in business
the universal skill in life really
because
in any Endeavor we plan out what we want
to do and we execute that plan and
that's project management whether you're
deciding to
buy a home or a car or fix something
um
need to plan out the steps you're going
to take
what schedules are going to occur in and
then execute them and make sure that
they're equally so in business sometimes
the stakes are higher but it's a similar
type of process and it's evolved over
the years we
traditionally thought of
project management in terms of discrete
steps that's that's very different today
isn't it Brian
it definitely in fact um
one of the things we've we've recognized
and seen in the industry in the market
is that it's the pace of change is just
so fast so high so some of those those
old style uh practices that you know we
we leveraged in the past very
prescriptive linear uh processes now
we're having to develop some very modern
project management techniques where
we're taking advantage of all these
digital tools that are starting to
emerge things like Ai and machine
learning which is actually really
helping the project management space so
all these uh skills are are so important
but as you pointed out they're sort of
the universal things that we're pulling
on here and some things just haven't
changed people are going to ask when is
it going to get done how much is it
going to cost and this is where project
management
um is is always sort of focused helping
organizations and people understand
those answers to those questions
excellent thank you um yeah it has
applications of course in every industry
every company and it's
really
extremely powerful because it allows you
to
um
control the flow of work within the
company both on the day-to-day level and
for
um one-off types of events
company for example simply learn just
acquired a company that was a project in
and of itself so
um
right project management skills
again the
skills of a project manager in the
traditional model
developed a project plan managed to
deliver both Staffing
thing so uh can can you comment a bit
about the
about these skills and how they're
maybe a little bit different in the
modern era of agile and scrum yeah great
great questions so yeah you know some of
the things you're seeing here definitely
universally applied to all types of
projects as I mentioned before
um you know you're gonna get asked as a
project manager often saving a teaching
courses the two questions you get asked
are how much is it going to cost and
when will it get done so we do need to
have a plan that helps support that and
we need to manage the deliverables that
people expect and get people to deliver
the work recruit staff all that's going
to be important but when we think of
sort of the domain the environment that
we're operating in right now
I mean it's got to be so responsive we
have to be so adaptive you know the best
laid plans often have to shift and
change we're seeing that all the time so
this is where that concept you mentioned
of agility starts entering into the mix
uh we want to develop project plans that
are adaptive that are flexible that are
responsive so uh so we're going to hear
a little bit more about that and that's
a real Cornerstone of this whole program
it's not just sort of I want to use a
term here your grandfather's project
management
um this is this new very Progressive Way
in which we can manage and deliver our
projects using techniques like agile
to talk a little bit further about what
does project management look like in
this new domain and this is an area that
you know I was spending a lot of time
with the project management Institute on
which is that project managed now
increasingly is getting spread out
across so many parts of the organization
a lot of organizations are realizing hey
keeping project management in just one
self-contained part of the company
organization isn't very impactful we
want everyone to have these skills and
we're going to hear a little bit more
about the career opportunities that
project management offers but I think
this is one of the more compelling ones
the need for these kinds of answers have
not gone away organizations are still
always going to need a way in which they
manage work and project managers are
going to be important part of doing that
and we're seeing that this is extending
across every aspect of an organization
now it's not just centralizing one
project management office so uh so kind
of exciting time if you're interested in
pursuing more of a formal project
management career Direction
and I did notice there were a couple
questions
um like you know what what technical
knowledge do good project managers bring
to the table
um now I will tell you this as a
consultant I work for many many
different organizations and a lot of
times I just don't have that domain
knowledge that some people in those
organizations that have been there 20
maybe 30 years have so it's not always
critical for a project manager to have
that in-depth technical knowledge
you're going to rely on expertise that
you have on your teams but great project
managers are the ones that can quickly
come up to speed on some of those
technical topics or the business domains
that they're operating in so uh and
that's part of what makes this a really
interesting industry I'm always shifting
into new projects learning about new
areas you know whether it's oil and gas
I'm based in Houston Texas to do a lot
of work in oil and gas but also
Healthcare do a lot of work with
Healthcare clients those are very
different Industries it's so fascinating
learning about how they operate and and
manage so
um so that makes project management I
think pretty exciting space to be in
okay
and you'll hear a little bit more from
Brian later
let's go back to our
presentation
so one of the things that
you need to have is a set of skills a
suite of skills
for project management PMP certification
professional project management
professional certification
um
offered by the project management
Institute is always a helpful
um certification to have
it shows that you've mastered a set of
skills according to an industry standard
that set of skills has evolved over the
years
so whereas 20 years ago a PMP
certification would have focused on a
traditional waterfall methods of project
management
today there's a significant component
for agile and agile scrum methods which
look at a different way of
organizing work and managing work
rather than the traditional step-by-step
approach
so risk management is also an important
element of project management because
you need to understand
what are the potential
pitfalls and downsides of any particular
project plan and how do you plan around
those so that you can keep your project
on schedule on budget on track
um lean Six Sigma methods for
maintaining quality
using tools like Microsoft Project and
other
planning and
management tools
implementation of a PML project
management office
so that you can set up a
function within your organization that
provides this type of support across
projects and then understanding
customer-centric digital transformation
because so much of what organizations do
today is deal with
digital transformation in our evolving
World especially since the pandemic
where
we had to move
almost instantly to
work from home
on contact
methods of dealing with customers
um the digital world became far more
important
um
and
customer-centric digital transformation
now and essential so
put together this Suite of project uh
management skills
let me ask uh because you're all here
because you're interested in this field
what has stopped you up until now
from
taking up this type of training
and let this poll run for a bit if you
are watching on the streaming services
you can put a b c d
into your chat or a comment
just let us know
I'll keep this going as long as I see
the the numbers are changing
and we're still coming
along here
give you about 15 seconds more to answer
but please get your answers in
and another five seconds
four
three
two
one hit that submit button
and here we go
this is very interesting because um
it's a very even distribution of all the
different uh
um
issues that identified here
barely
the most
is
time in the work schedule finding the
time to um
put in the study
get the skills
um
right after that is not feeling that you
get practical exposure or experience
that you would be able to use to
demonstrate your new skills
um not finding a fully comprehensive
curriculum it covers all of those
project management skills that discussed
and
um also
when Phillips find it difficult to learn
from pre-recorded videos
as a primary mode of
education so
let me share that with you
you can see that fairly straightforward
fairly even distribution I should say
so
that brings us to the program at hand at
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
Eisenberg School of Management offers
the postgraduate program in project
management
this is uh delivered by simply learn
um and it is a six-month program
we say that you should plant a devote 10
to 15 hours a week
um some of that is in scheduled classes
uh generally on the weekends but much of
that is
work you can do on your own schedule
um anytime on the digital platform is
available to you 24 7.
and it is entirely delivered online
um so
you have the ability to take this course
from
virtually anywhere in the world and
desktop your laptop much of a material
can be accessed on your mobile device
so this is a
very convenient program and something
that you can fit into your schedule and
into your lifestyle it covers a
comprehensive curriculum and we'll get
into that shortly and it includes
integrated case studies and Hands-On
projects that you'll be doing to build
up a portfolio that you can then show
off say this is the proof that I can do
this type of work
the live classes are done uh virtually
online
but you're directly interacting live
with your instructors and with your
peers in the classroom you get to ask
your questions live get responses
um go through the exercises and case
studies live with the professors
so uh or instructors I should say and
then this gives you a ability to to
um
learn in a
live classroom environment from wherever
you are
oh
but you get out of the program is
a certificate that
attests to the fact that you've
completed
the program
demonstrated the skills
backed by the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst
uh it's also backed by simply learn and
along the way you have done those case
studies and projects that I mentioned
including a Capstone project which comes
at the end of the course and ties
together all of the different
skills that you've learned along the way
talk a little bit more about that you
also get master classes
should say that
I'm sure I'm going to say that you do
get
University of Massachusetts Amherst
Alumni Association membership
Eisenberg Advantage the Eisenberg School
is a one of the oldest
um business schools schools of
management in the United States
um the university itself was established
130 years ago and the um School of
Management was founded right after World
War II which was
a time of
great Innovation and blossoming of
management technology management Theory
management skills
um
the world had just learned how to scale
up production to a very massive scale
because of the second World War
this type of knowledge
became the standard for business schools
at the time and of course it's evolved
greatly since then so
we live in a very different world from
1947 but the uh
Eisenberg school has kept up with the
advances in management Theory and
this program gives you the certificates
the Alumni Association it gives you nine
credits transferable to an Eisenberg
online MBA program so if you want to
um
follow up on the program and start an
actual MBA program
through the uh
UMass online
you can do that you have a head start
with nine credits so
have a University of Massachusetts
Amherst on your your CV is actually a
very prestigious
mark
to recognize worldwide as one of the top
universities and so
that will be something that you can
proudly show off to people
to be eligible for this program
you need a bachelor's degree this is a
postgraduate program so you do have to
have a bachelor's degree it can be in
any discipline it does not have to be in
technology does not have to be in
management
not have to be in
science technology business
mathematics
you can come in from a liberal arts
background you do have to have work
experience and this program requires
that you've been in the workforce for at
least five years
not necessarily in the project
management capacity but in whatever
capacity
it's important to understand how
organizations work and what
what this type of work project
management work does within the
organization context again you don't
have to have a programming background
you'll be using some digital tools but
you do not have to come in with
programming skills
so it's a pretty straightforward as long
as you've got your bachelor's degree and
have been working for five years you
pretty much um
are qualified for the program
let me then ask a question how many
years of experience that people in the
audience have
watch
and this is a pretty straightforward
question so I'll only leave it open for
about 20 or 30 seconds here
watching the answers come in
and get your answers in please in the
next five seconds
three two
one
and I'll share the result
so almost sixty percent of the audience
fifty seven percent of our audience have
more than five years experience that's
the
qualifications so
um for that group of people certainly
you
meet that Criterion during the three to
five years experience you'll probably
need to uh
plan ahead
year or two down the road for this
program people in the lower experience
categories probably want to look ahead
further than that
so
but for the folks who have
five years or nearly five years
experience let's talk about
how this program prepares you
and
we're going to have a live tour of the
learning environment I'm going to um
have that in just a few moments we're
going to have a Brian
picking on that but in the meantime I'm
going to tell you about the
curriculum
and this program is designed
to build your skills up in a stepwise
fashion
you start off with an orientation
session that gets you
um
oriented to the digital environment to
the learning management system to the
content that you're going to expect what
courses you'll be taking
and then
you'll get into the program again with
live classes the first module being
preparing for the project management
professional
certification one of the reasons why we
require a five years
experience
Criterion is PMP certification requires
that you have a certain amount of
experience so you can't just come in
to that without work experience
um once you've prepared for that and you
have the exam certificate or exam
voucher that allows you to take that
exam
um then you move on to the agile scrum
master module that teaches you
those skills how to
use agile techniques and and the scrum
method to manage projects
um
then you move on to Microsoft Project
and learning how to use that tool
and uh last module before the Capstone
is implementing the project management
office so understanding the function
within the organization and how to
formalize it
and the final module of the program is
the Capstone project which is a three to
four week effort you do that under the
mentorship of one of your instructors
uh you
you create a solution to a project
management challenge that's based on an
industry problem and that solution
becomes part of your permanent portfolio
along the way you can take any or all of
the objective electives
that come through the um
these are all included at no extra cost
so you have a risk management
professional
PMI
certification lead Six Sigma
customer-centric digital transformation
and the
PMP
certification so
yeah
you will
use and you will be required to to
master
a number of different Frameworks and
tools for project management so at the
end of the
program
you'll be able to put these onto your
resume and be able to say here is how I
use them
and this is how I
applied them in the coursework so
um
agile uh the project management book of
knowledge
a lean Six Sigma jira office project all
of these types of of tools
and as I mentioned the Capstone project
gives you
um
a showcase
that lets you demonstrate all the skills
that you picked up during the program
and you apply them to an industry-based
problem given several to choose from
you pick one and you work uh on that for
three to four weeks with
the mentorship of your instructor
I'll meet with you weekly to make sure
you're not going down in the rabbit
holes or encountering any blockers
and
you'll end up with a
finished project that you built
that you then have in your portfolio
then demonstrate to your current or
future employers
this is how I approach project
management and this is how I Implement
project Management Solutions so
the very valuable part of the program
so at this point I'm going to
have Brian share
the
um
media tour of the Learning Management
excellent okay so you heard me talk a
bit I kind of ran through the list here
of courses so these are the courses now
you can kind of visualize it a little
more uh in addition to hearing me talk
about it so you can see the different
courses we've got
um each one of these are a little tile
very easy to both visually see
understand what they are and dive into
notice a few of these are going to say
self-learning and live classes so some
of this is self-paced learning you can
take the content the videos that have
been recorded you can start uh looking
at that you know whenever it's
convenient and then there's gonna be
live courses taught by people like
myself and other
um Experience Project program managers
so you'll have a chance to kind of also
attend those sessions so a couple
different flavors in which you can
pursue
um we're just about after it gone
through the list of all the different
courses here you can see them
um I was just about to click on a few so
you can see them a little more directly
so let's click on our PMP now this one
has an update and that's I think a
really important thing to be aware of
similar is always investing in the
content that they've created making sure
it's up to date that it reflects current
trends and directions now I'm not going
to update it right now just to save us
the time so I'm just going to reserve
learning but I think that's really
important to call out
so you can see right off the bat
I'm jumping into a video so we've got a
uh uh on the right hand side sort of our
course content here and you can jump to
any part of the course content we've got
videos that are going to come up so
these are really engaging you can see
how a professional these look so they've
uh really invested in creating a
positive learning experience for y'all
uh in addition to the self-learning and
the videos you have you've got some
assessments you can take
and you can then mine's already expired
um because I'm an instructor so they
just give me this uh hopefully I need it
so I said that in this particular case
you could take an assessment you've got
four assessments you can take
and for anyone that's interested in
taking the PMP certification exam this
is incredibly valuable because it gives
you a chance to practice this is a very
demanding exam so having an opportunity
to kind of practice and get some
exposure to the types of questions and
make sure you really understand all the
content is very very valuable you can
see in the left hand side too if we look
at the screen here we've got our live
classes okay you'll be able to see a
list of when the live classes are you
can check on your certificate once
you've completed all the necessary
activities you will unlock this
achievement and immediately you can add
that to your portfolio is something
you've accomplished so each one of the
courses has this type of structure which
makes it from my perspective really easy
to get to what you need to learn and get
ways in which you can validate your
learning so each one of these programs
has the the same structure you're going
to have different course is you can
click into we can look at things like
the agile scrum master
and it's the same structures format so
that consistency is helpful you know you
don't have to relearn things every time
you go into each one of the courses
again the same high quality learning
experience notice there's some tooling
that starts to merge we've got some
self-learning we've got a project this
time a smart weather with jira jira is a
a very prominent industry-leading agile
Work Management tools you can actually
get a chance to see these tools in
action learn about them we've got
reference materials things like case
studies you can take you can download
the course slides if you want to go back
through those so anyways really really
rich experience I do want to bring your
attention to one other thing that I
think is really impactful is this
community button one of the things
simply learned is known for is a great
Community although they're Learners so
you'll be able to engage with your
learning cohort all the other people
involved in the program and structures
like myself are in the forums if you
have a question if there's a topic you
want to dig into you can post it there
instructors and other student
participants will all be able to kind of
chat and talk about this so I find that
really enriches The Learning Experience
Stuart what else what else should I show
I think you mentioned the community
forums and
um
are there any other
resources like the files that the
instructors share with students other
resource sections that people go through
definitely definitely so yeah you'll see
in each of the courses uh there will be
things like case studies you can click
on this link case studies zip file will
be downloaded you can spend some time uh
digging through each of those
okay so that was a
brief tour of the
learning management system
and
this program is under the direction of
John Wells the
head of lifelong learning at University
of Massachusetts Amherst
and
again simply learned as a delivery
partner for the program
but the the
design of the program the curriculum is
put together
by uh
UMass Amherst so that's how they can put
their
Full Faith and uh
reputation behind it
let's talk a little bit about learner
outcomes
get to your questions shortly
so here are some of the people who've
succeeded through
this type this this program
um we have
uh oh who is uh
one of the people who
finished the program and see here that
he really enjoyed the instruction
um found that it
supported his learning very well
um Dale says something similar
um
prachi talks about how the learning
experience was really great
um jotish
um
enjoyed the classes
complimented the trainer these are all
people who have succeeded
through this program
there are a number of them and many more
one thing I want to mention
um
another way that
we help you succeed
through a career assist service
the job assist program that we offer is
four Learners in India only so we do not
offer that in um
other countries at present but if you
are a Learner in India
um and you take this program
you will receive uh for six months after
you receive your certificate you'll
receive
um
career assist services to support your
job search
so some of those are in the form of
webinars and other free
content that we provide to help you in
keeping your career on track we also
provide part of that in the projects
that you do as part of this program but
the the formal job assist Services come
from IIM jobs in India and they have
three important parts the first part is
the IAM jobs job portal which gives you
access to exclusive job listings
um
we think that that's a very valuable
service
um personally I think the other two
parts of the service are even more
valuable
uh resume resume review and rewrite
service is important because today's
job Seekers have to get through
the automated tracking systems that
employers use and the AI Bots that
filter out
resumes before they ever get to a human
to evaluate so
knowing how to write a resume so that
the AI bot will recognize your skills
and match them to the job description uh
is an important
almost art form
the thing that raises it to a true art
form is that once you get through that
filter
your resume still has to serve as the
function of appealing to the eyes of
human beings on their desktops or on
their screens and so
being able to do both of those things
with the resume
extremely valuable
help
the other thing that's extremely
valuable is the one-on-one interview
prep service
you need to pass through several layers
of interviews
part of your job search if you
get your res you know resume through the
filter process and somebody finds it
attractive and calls you in for
interviews
which they may do
remotely or they may do in person you
need to be prepared to take those
interviews and put your best foot
forward
some of the interviews will be on your
technical skills what do you know about
project management some of the
interviews will be on your cultural fit
with the company how well do you fit in
with the team so being able to Ace those
interviews of both types
something that
really increases your likelihood of
finding a job so again the job assist
services are not a job guarantee
but they are services that will help you
in your job search
as I mentioned there are webinars
industry experts with
people who talk about career skills
career coaching
um
different
particular technical Fields the state of
the art what types of training programs
you should focus on so all of this is
free it's available to you on an ongoing
basis
and of course the projects that you do
as part of this program
become your
portfolio to demonstrate
your skills to potential employers so
with all of those things
and what we've said so far up until now
today are you interested
in enrolling in this program
let me let this poll run briefly of
course this is
one question Paul so yes or no
so I'm not going to leave it open for
terribly long but
give it another 15 seconds or so
okay and I'll close the poll in about
five
or
three
[Music]
two
one so please hit submit here you go
almost 90 percent of the people who
responded said that they are interested
which is great I will share with you how
how to accomplish that
I'm sure they see that
and
well the enrollment steps are very
straightforward you
submit your application to Simply learn
uh as our as the delivery partner we
take in that and administer that part of
the
process
you email us at ask us simplylearn.net
what I will do right now
I'm going to put that email address
along with
link to our program page
into the chat right now
here we go
so you should have that link in the chat
we evaluate the application we'll ask
you for information about your work
experience and documentation for that
we'll ask you about your
bachelor's degree documentation for that
and evaluate your level of interest and
commitment to learning about product
project management
and
assuming you pass all of those criteria
then we will send you an admission offer
and to let you know
the next group of classes uh starts in
February 25th of February there's
actually an orientation tomorrow
uh although if you don't sign up by
tomorrow you will be able to make a
different orientation before the 25th of
February
that's our next cohort
if you are in India the price of the
program is one lock
uh 12 455 rupee
um with the
financing available
format's a little weird but
3733 per month over time until that's
paid off
um so that's zero cost financing
um and that gives you an option to um
get into the program without committing
the full lump sum up front if you are
anywhere else in the world the price is
in US dollars two thousand four hundred
and ninety nine and you can inquire
about financing options
um but again get the process start
please
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
help you
so for those of you who are interested
how soon would you like to start
something you want to do on the February
last group or is it something that you
want to do maybe further out
I'll leave this open
we'll let you ponder that for about
another 15 seconds or so
please get your answers in
all right and I'll close the poll in
five seconds
please hit the submit button
closing the poll
now
so about 15 of the respondents said that
they are interested in that next cohort
in February
um
and about twice as many or so are
interested in maybe the cohort that
happens in March or April
um if you're looking further out
please do contact us either way because
the learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net will be able to tell you
about what the future dates will be
answer any questions that you have about
the program and
keep you in touch with us let you know
and remind you as you get closer to the
date where you'd like to get enrolled so
and this is if this is something that
will improve your life and your career
um we always recommend that you do it
sooner than later but
um we're here to help you whenever you
choose to do it
so let's
move on to questions and answers at this
point you don't need to see the
slide anymore I'm going to go through
first check to see if we have questions
that have come in
don't see any that have come in from our
streaming services yet
but we have quite a lot
we've come in Via Zoom so
let me
run through that
coming down
the question is of course free
or how much of the fees we just covered
that so
okay
uh we do not offer a proof of attendance
certificate for today's webinar
um this is
uh we do
provide that for the
career building and Technology expert
webinars that I mentioned
if you attend those you do get proof of
attendance certificates
see what else
a lot of these are comments so
question about customer-centric digital
transformation
um so
there is a
I mentioned an elective on
customer-centric digital transformation
talks about how
your organization's processes
can be brought into the digital domain
and done in a way that
keeps the customers requirements the
user's requirements foremost so that's a
important distinction in the past
implementation of digital systems often
focused on the efficiency within the
organization what was convenient for the
organization what was most efficient for
the organization today
the
standard is to make the process
efficient and comfortable and delightful
for the user because by doing that you
increase What's called the stickiness of
the process where users will stay with
you and your organization's
services and products so this is an
important aspect of it and
the it fits in with project management
because so much of the work that people
do in projects management today involves
or is involved with digital
transformation
program duration is six months
that includes all the modules
to looking through here
uh
before or after PMP certification Rahul
the uh if I understand your question
correctly
do you take this before or do you take
this after PMP certification and the
answer is it's during because this
program will prepare you for your PMP
certification
um that's part of the the
postgraduate program so it's going to
give you uh the skills that
covered in the different modules
as well as preparing you for the PMP
exam
down
how long does it take to complete the
course
and
what happens if you can't finish in the
stipulated time so uh
the course of six months
um the
learning management system will help you
stay in on track for that if there are
problems that arise where you have some
type of challenge or issue that requires
you to delay we can work with you to get
you from one cohort of the program into
a later cohort to complete it there is a
requirement however to complete within a
certain amount of time so you'll want to
ask ask us at simplylearn.net ask the
learning Consultants there and
find out what the policies are for that
what are the mandatory skills to join
the course
you have to have the work experience you
have to have the bachelor's degree and
you have to have the interest in project
management but other than that there are
no mandatory skills per se
um
okay
is the pgp and project management
equivalent to the first year of a
master's degree this pgmp project
management is equivalent to nine units
of a master's of business administration
because in fact if you complete this
program
you have nine credits available that you
can transfer into an online MBA with the
University of Massachusetts so
um that's
uh
what I can tell you about that cartic
acid research experience the PHD
research scholar for five years counts
as experience
um I believe it will Karthik um and I
would say that you would want to double
check that with the folks that with the
learning Consultants but certainly
that's work experience
after graduating uh bachelor's degree so
it's absolutely uh
it seems to me that that would be
experience
I was told by simply learning last year
while looking at this program initially
I didn't have a bachelor's degree I'm
not sure why you were told that this is
a postgraduate program this particular
program does require a bachelor's degree
there are other training programs that
simply learn offers
that are of a different nature that
don't require a bachelor's degree but
that's uh
that doesn't apply to this
what are the requirements for BSC and
computer science with respect to this
program Abraham there is no
um
requirement for a bachelor's degree in
computer science you can have a
bachelor's degree in any field
okay and I'm looking we're almost
end here
does One require any knowledge of
project management
um
would this pgp be helpful if I'm
starting in my MBA
um so yeah it depends on what your focus
or concentration in your MBA is going to
be
um but certainly
project management skills are extremely
important for anybody in management
um because
management
is either ongoing operations or it's
implementing change within the
organization so
if you're doing ongoing operations and
you're organizing work to be done the
same way every day
that's operational management if you're
doing
um
change to the way the business does work
or you're implementing
research or developing a new product all
of those types of
activities require project management
skills so
um
would want to ask our learning
Consultants but certainly
having these project management skills
is very important and the tie into the
MBA as I mentioned is that
University of Massachusetts Amherst
recognizes the the
content of this course as uh important
for an MBA program so that they offer
credit for their online MBA for this
course so
uh
see
PMP requires experience from no more
than eight years ago minus from 12 years
ago which is therefore invalid
um Lisa you'll probably want to to ask
that question of the learning
Consultants
you may be correct about that and
um but
there may be uh grandfathering in there
um
and
I wanted to double check how does the
nine unit transfer work if I were also
to apply for the MBA
and the online MBA is 37 to 39 units
does that mean I only have to take
30 units to complete the MBA that's
exactly right
um
you complete this program and you apply
for the UMass MBA online
um they will credit United units which
means you only have 30 left to go
and um
Street transfer transfer
uh someone asks about getting a PPT of
this particular webinar you'll get a a
link to the recording
and
so you'll be able to review this
information and
go down almost at the end
ah Tanya says I'm participating in the
January 2023 cohort for this program
what is the registration process to
proceed with the MBA uh ask our learning
consultants and they can put you in
touch also with uh the appropriate
people at UMass Amherst to get you into
that process as well
uh
uh appys is there's the possibility to
get this class schedule in advance and
certainly
can do that through the learning
Consultants
and
do we have a scholarship scheme we do
not we only have the um
zero cost financing scheme
um how do you describe the importance of
project management in one sentence
sentence I would use is project
management is
the methodology for getting things done
pretty much
all it is
um
it's how you figure out
what needs to be done
when it needs to be done and how much it
will cost
another an alternate sentence
uh
Jose I believe the cost of the PMP
certification is included in the course
and you'll get a voucher for the the
exam
double check that with the uh
learning Consultants
see
is lean Six Sigma optional course as a
certificate or certification once
completed I'm not absolutely sure about
the
certification process within like lean
Six Sigma optional course I believe your
Green Belt certification is included in
that
um and again the elective course is
included at no additional cost
uh
uh are sending a recording
what are the okay what are the
attendance requirements for live classes
it's a great question
um and do you have to attend a certain
percentage of the live classes
uh real-time live when they when they
occur so you'll need to check that
schedule
um if you miss some of the classes
occasionally uh they are recorded and
you can catch up with them but there's a
requirement to commit to getting to the
the live classes a certain percentage of
the time
uh
I want to ask this question about scrum
Master uh
uh
scrum master program includes CSM so
you'd want to ask the learning
Consultants that
and
you have a question about
would we advise someone to take capm
first or directly to PMI PMP
certification
um and this program is designed to help
you
go straight into the PMP certification
so
um but you can ask that question of the
um
learning Consultants as well
just
scrolling to the bottom here
uh
I have a bachelor some procurement can I
take PMP and pgmp
um so
yes if you have a bachelor's in
procurement you can take this program
which will prepare you and qualify you
for the PMP so
okay bachelor's uh
become
diploma and project management completed
in 2011.
uh
I would ask the learning Consultants
this question about a relationship
between capm and getting experience for
the PMP so
and
we can't enroll in the February session
when does the next one after that that's
in March
are the lectures recorded alive
lectures live they're recorded in case
you missed them live and
watch the recordings to catch up
well the prospects for freelancing or
consultant work in this field last
question I'll be able to take
but the prospects are excellent because
um as Brian mentioned
you do not always have to have deep
domain knowledge in order to be able to
to be a project manager in a particular
area because
much of what you would do as a
consultant or a freelance project
manager is to organize the work
um
without necessarily being a subject
matter expert
hope that answers your question that's
all the time we have I'm going to ask
one less
question of our audience here today
our question is uh if you're planning to
enroll do you need assistance from us in
getting enrolled
so I'll leave this open
for about 15 or 20 seconds
and for assistance you would contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net
I will put that into the chat again
sorry
and just put that back into the chat so
it's at your fingertips
and I will end the poll in five four
three two one
and about half of the respondents said
that they are interested
getting assistance so again
contact us at ask us simplylearn.net
that QR code will take you to the
program home page on our website
um
I want to thank everyone who joined us
today
for this webinar
we hope that we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with UMass Amherst
and simplylearn
and that concludes our webinar for today
thank you very much